i miss you too man what's going on over
there you know what it is missing
not a goddamn thing joey you haven't
been missing anything
you're looking at the you're looking at
the lone wolf man
i'm all by myself out here now rogan
left
you left theo left everybody else got
canceled
so i'm out here by myself brother
josh wolf left already he leaves
i think in a week or two to nashville
wow
i know man how's it looking over there
you know it looks like freaking zombie
apocalypse man
same as when you left so i don't you
know i
i'm just gonna i'm giving it six months
before i make any
irrational decisions yeah i was you know
i started looking at properties in
in texas i started looking in nashville
i started looking all over and then i
was like you know because i'm moving the
whole family kids mother-in-law
father-in-law so i decided not to rush
into anything
just give it about six to eight months
before i decide it's just
just to see how everything plays out let
the election go on but
i'll tell you you and joe leaving man
that that was uh
that was tough man you know i feel super
alone out here i'll be honest with you
joey
i felt super alone out there when i was
there with everybody there i never saw
anybody you know
yeah we got to see each other at the
score and that was it you know
this is a lot of people don't understand
i was
i was coming to new york the week of the
night
to do comedy and just finish shooting a
movie
and i was gonna go i had i was doing
niacc
on the 12th and that morning
i was going to look at houses
in bergen county so i was already
thinking of moving
way before this before everything hit
yeah we i was going to look at the house
in march
and we had plane tickets for april 4th
to come back my wife was going to look
at the house
my daughter and then we were going to
decide when and buy it
we were going to move in april oh damn i
had just never told anybody
oh damn i it was it was nobody's
business so i didn't talk about it
that's fair i was come i was coming back
here march
10th to stay till this 18th
and in that time i was gonna look at a
few houses that my wife had already
picked out
all the new jobs yeah
up north though i'm closer to new york
city you're going to live like in
bergenfield somewhere up you know 10
minutes from new york city type deal
yeah that was the original plan i had
i had already the tickets for april 4th
and then we were going to come as a
family
look at the houses and then we were
going to come in september probably
and you just wanted to get out of la
joey what what was or you just missed
your family back there
you know i came back to shoot a movie
for three weeks and i was walking around
the city i'm walking around
jersey and i just thought to myself what
the [ __ ] am i doing right
i meet him at the store three nights a
week and i do two podcasts i'm either on
the road
two three nights a week and i'm doing
two podcasts
i box i lift and i spend time with the
kid it was like
you know it was like i was happy about
what was going on
but it was it was becoming too easy yeah
too comfortable i had i i was i was too
comfortable everything was two blocks in
my house
so i and that was one reason and the
other reason
i was just sick of being alone i was
sick of spending christmases alone i
would look at you know facebook
and see my friends in jersey even like
[ __ ] savages
peppers and all this [ __ ] the good stuff
and i'm [ __ ] in la you know alone
on the holidays with a couple stragglers
that don't have families
and it was just time to leave it was
just time to go that's it
i've been here a while though man you
know like my wife said something to me
she said you know with with joe and with
joey they've been here a lot longer than
you they've been doing it so much longer
so
for them to feel like they you know
they've they've done what they need to
do in la they've been
you guys been doing it in what 20 30
years man
i was in l.a for 23 years a long time
joey
that's a long [ __ ] time i did my time
i did the movies i did the tv show
i did the specials you know i was at the
store the whole [ __ ] time
yeah i remember i became a regular at
the store a month into being the la
jesus so i was at the store the whole
time i took that seven year drop
off when things were confusing for a
while at the store
but besides that and then we went you
know we were at the store
maybe uh 10 years
and then i stopped going and the store
was completely different
when we went back we went back as like
[ __ ] og's yep
so it was a different comedy store it
was completely different
i loved it i missed it like [ __ ] i
missed the comedy store all the way down
to my toes but
basically that's the only thing i miss
in a way you know even with my podcast
i miss it like [ __ ] i miss league i miss
not doing it
but i know it was time for something new
how did you know john
i've never been the ass to leave a room
i take pride in that
i've never been asked to leave a [ __ ]
room because somebody has to have a
conversation
yeah you know like if you have to if you
have to talk to rogan and you want to
talk to him alone you don't have to tell
me
i i know your body language yeah you
know so you
never have to i take pride and somebody
not having to tell me i have to leave
it was 23 years you know
i'm i did it basically for my family i
did it so they could have a normal
[ __ ] life
yeah you know my my daughter's not in
the business and my wife is not in the
business
why should she be surrounded with those
[ __ ] months
yeah you know and it was at her school
you know anywhere you went it was like
you're being judged by your twitter
numbers
or your followers on [ __ ] instagram
you know
judge me for being a [ __ ] man not the
[ __ ] i know having a million
followers you know
so it just got a little bit [ __ ] up
and i wanted to bring it back to normal
this was the only way
i could do this normally and trust me i
went through tons of anxiety over this
you know i lost sleep but you know what
my daughter's in school twice a week
she's happy
today there was no school it's a jewish
holiday here that's right so i took it
to the [ __ ] park and she had a play
dead at the park to 1 30
we came home now my daughter my wife
took it before a flu shot
then we take it for kickboxing at five
and that's it
man that's my [ __ ] day when i get off
stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son